you
I do think they should and I do but I
think it's important to distinguish the
different hats for the bioethicists
wears when i'm in the classroom a brown
or NYU or Columbia I make a point of not
telling the students how I feel about
topical or hot button issues they can
certainly go online or find in journals
my viewpoints but few of them do and you
really want to be an arbiter you want to
be an impartial judge letting them come
to their own conclusions in the same way
in the hospital you want to let families
reach their own conclusions and you want
to show them viewpoints you don't agree
with as well as ones you do in contrast
as a public intellectual or a public
figure engaged in the discourse you
should be advocating for a particular
position what I'd like to tell the
students at Brown and mr. Ives it's not
my idea it's something Vartan Gregorian
the former president of Brown said in
the commencement address about 10 years
ago he said the problem with modern
universities paraphrasing on the problem
with modern universities is that they
break down all of the students
preconceived notions but don't give them
any new ideas and they leave the
university believing that all ideas of
equal value and hence in some sense
believing in nothing I think it's
important to have all of your ideas
broken down to be able to see that
people who disagree with you are an
idiot's that they simply start with
different premises and have different
value sets and come to logical
conclusions based on them but once you
do that it's also important to operate
in the world where they deeply help set
of beliefs that you can fight for and
the two are not mutually exclusive
I think historically there was much more
friction than there is today
historically physicians lived in a
fairly into the world and the
bioethicists were often clergyman or
philosophers who came in with moral
judgments that were often detached from
the field of medicine as the brilliant
epics thinker and clinician Ken Prager
at Columbia University says all good
ethical decisions should stem from the
facts of the case as we have more
physicians who have become bioethicists
and as the bioethics field now
increasingly they feel populated by
physicians and clinicians who happen to
practice ethics that conflict is largely
evaporating we're all on the same page